being a profitable is virtually useless
for modern companies Founders don't care
about profit shareholders don't care
about profit and even employees don't
care about profit this has resulted in
an era of money losing Giants in the
last 12 months Zillow lost 101 million
dollars wework lost 2.7 billion Snapchat
lost 1.43 billion and Uber lost wait for
it 9.1 billion traditionally such losses
would be a nightmare for owners if they
don't turn around the company sooner
bankruptcy would be a high probability
but modern companies don't really care
what they all care about instead is a
growth and lots of it as long as the
company is growing any loss is deemed
acceptable it's not just these new
startups that have been going down this
path either Tech Giants have been using
this strategy for decades Amazon for
example has always teetered on the edge
of profitability and their retail
business is still unprofitable to this
day a similar story can be said about
Google as well Google is a cash cow but
that's only due to one business they're
out of business virtually everything
else is a loss their Cloud business for
example lost 480 Million last quarter
and as for Facebook I mean do I even
have to say anything about the metaverse
some more Legacy companies have also
turned to this strategy in recent times
like Disney Walt Disney is still
profitable as a company they're
definitely using the modern approach
when it comes to new services like
Disney plus despite having hundreds of
millions of subscribers Disney streaming
lost 1.5 billion in the last quarter
alone and it's not like these companies
are forced into losses most of them
could raise prices cut marketing lower
reinvestment and become profitable
basically overnight but they actively
choose not to because want it they can
afford it and the two they actually
think that it's the better play long
term it wasn't always like this though
back in the day Prophet was King owners
needed profit to pay themselves they
needed profits to pay shareholders and
they needed profits to pay employees
bonuses and additional perks so whether
you are running an oil business or a
steel business the goal was to achieve
profitability as quickly as possible but
over time the urgency to reach
profitability slowly withered away
instead of having a 3 6 or 12 month
timeline to reach profitability owners
started having two private 10 year-long
time frames and now it seems like this
time frame has expanded to Encompass
Infinity so here's the story of how
everyone involved in a company from
shareholders to employees slowly
accepted it in definite losses
while this acceptance of no profit and
losses may seem like a new trend and
it's actually been developing for a
hundred years and dates back to World
War One such large-scale Wars are
naturally full Nation efforts so it's
not surprising that the government
expected everyone to step up and offer
their knowledge and expertise to the
government this of course included
companies and their Executives who were
especially important in scaling
production managing Logistics and
negotiating deals with contractors but
there was just one problem laws
prevented the government from accepting
services from unpaid volunteers but with
that being said the government also
wasn't willing to pay these Executives
as a potential salary because one they
were already rich and the two this was
more of a service than a job so they
would eventually settle on paying these
Executives at one dollar salaries some
of the earliest examples of this were
Bernard Baruch Robert S Brookings and
Herbert swab who all served on World War
One advisory commissions this practice
just became even more common during
World War II with even more notable
people participating in the one dollar a
year service likely the best example of
this was William nutsener who was the
CEO of GM but after the war came to a
close and the U.S entered one of the
most prosperous periods of its history
the one dollar salary was more or less
forgotten about and it wasn't until the
1970s that we would see another
Resurgence of this trend the automobile
industry would be hit hard by the 1970s
Not only was there ludicrous amounts of
inflation but the Middle East would join
forces and impose a devastating Oil
Embargo on the U.S and the most Western
countries to make things worse Japanese
cars were also starting to gain
popularity the American automotive
company that was likely hurt the most
was Chrysler by the late 1970s the
company was on the brink of bankruptcy
and and was in dire need of a bailout so
Chrysler CEO Lee Iacocca were to begin
lobbying Congress for a bailout and to
show that he was serious about it
turning around the company and not just
pocketing a bailout he would offer to
take a one dollar salary Chrysler would
end up receiving the bailout and the
Iacocca would stage one of the biggest
turnarounds the automotive industry has
ever seen But the biggest ticking factor
for many of his peers was not his
business Excellence but his one dollar
salary you see it back in the 70s and
early 80s taxes were really bad in fact
if you made more than 215 000 per year
you had to pay income tax of 70 percent
but long-term capital gains tax was much
more reasonable at 28 so for obvious
reasons Founders trended towards
decreasing their cash compensation and
increasing their stock compensation they
didn't take this to the extreme of
taking one dollar salaries but this is
eventually where it led to what Steve
Jobs when Steve Jobs returned to Apple
in the late 1990s he would accept a one
dollar salary he didn't do this to
decrease taxes or earn more stock
compensation or really any Financial
reason rather he was trying to make a
statement that he was there to save
Apple not to make money but it didn't
take long for other Tech CEOs to make
this into a trend from their perspective
this was a win-win-win-win scenario they
could reduce public criticism about
their salaries boards could approve
stock compensation plans at a magnitude
that was simply impossible with cash
stock had extraordinary growth potential
and the founders and CEOs could get away
with paying far less in taxes now of
course these leaders still had to make
sure the company was profitable because
that's what kept the stock price high
but this was quickly changing as well
because the next Domino to fall were
shareholders
[Music]
traditionally one of the most attractive
features of stock was their dividend
this makes sense as this is what really
makes you feel like an owner of the
company every quarter you get a share of
the company's profits this is why many
traditional companies like Exxon and
Coca-Cola swear by their dividend
payments Exxon has paid dividends for
112 years and they haven't even missed a
single payment this isn't to say that
Exxon was always performing well though
in fact in many years like 2020 they
were actually doing quite bad but they
paid a dividend anyway because like I
said they swear by it historically
Dividends are What attracted investors
like Warren Buffett to a stock
the big benefits
of exempting dividends would go to
fellows like me and Charlie you know and
that's not going to stimulate the
economy it's going to stimulate us so
maintaining a Pristina dividend
reputation was vital for such companies
we should also mention that for many
stocks this was their primary return I
mean steel companies and insurance
companies weren't going to double every
year more realistically they were gonna
grow five or ten percent for a few
decades and then top out so the dividend
is what made stocks like at T which
hasn't moved in 30 years worth owning
but all of this would change would be
internet suddenly companies were able to
go 100 every year for 10 years trade and
then grow 50 every year for the next 10
years and the company that really
solidified this notion was none other
than Amazon
while Amazon's retail business was never
that profitable they did find a gold
mine called Amazon web services if a
Jeff Bezos really wanted to he could
have leaned in on AWS raised the prices
of Prima bid and started paying out
solid dividends but this made no sense
to Jeff you see Jeff had already
subscribed to the idea of no cash
compensation for himself he took a very
modest salary of 81 to 840 throughout
his entire career at Amazon for Jeff the
money was in the stock not the bottom
line and he wanted investors to get on
the same page fortunately for Jeff there
was a new but rapidly growing subset of
investors called growth investors were
getting on the same page most of these
investors weren't fans of dividends and
they saw dividends as a complete waste
of capital due to taxes if you didn't
know Dividends are taxed twice once at
the corporate level and the ones at the
investor level this means that if Amazon
was gonna pay one dollar in dividends
they would first have to pay about 25
percent in corporate tax meaning that
only 75 cents would make it to the
investor from there the investor would
have to pay personal income tax on that
75 cents and the given that most
investors with the size of bus take or
already pretty well off they usually
have to pay 40 percent of this dividend
to taxes and yes I know that some
companies are able to pay tax exempt to
dividends but that's not always the case
so bear with me here with the 40 income
tax the investor is only left with a
mere 45 cents the worst part is that
many of these investors are just looking
to reinvest the dividends anyway so it
makes no sense for Amazon to pay out a
dividend only for the government to take
55 and then have 45 percent to come back
to Amazon instead Amazon can just
reinvest a hundred percent of their
profits themselves and that's exactly
what Amazon has done for the longest
time value investors would ridicule
Amazon and these so-called growth
investors but over the past 10 years
growth stocks have taken over the market
most of the big tech companies pay
little to no dividends and that all of
the returns for investors are from
growth and since then even Warren
Buffett has to invest in Amazon so there
was only one more group to convert to
the dark side employees
like shareholders employees have
historically attended towards profitable
companies after all for employees
joining a company isn't just an
investment it's their livelihoods also
traditionally employees used to stick
around at the same company for their
entire careers so choosing a stable
company with large profit margins was
essential but over time employees have
become more random more risk tolerant
for wanna employees no longer feel that
they're tied down to one company in fact
they've realized that their peers who
constantly switch companies tend to earn
a lot more money so employees today are
a lot more likely to join a startup or a
company that's trying to Stage a
turnaround sure it might not work but in
that case they can just find another job
if it does work though they suddenly
become a key member at this new company
maybe even an executive but nowadays you
don't even have to become an executive
to cash in on many of the same perks
like stock compensation historically
employees may have refused to take stock
compensation because it's inherently
riskier but as we said employees are
willing to take a lot more risk nowadays
not to mention they're a lot more aware
of how the wealthy people make their
money they see the Fortune 500 list they
see billionaires and they see YouTube
videos like this and they realize that
if they want to become a truly wealthy
they have their own assets like real
estate and stock so naturally more and
more employees started looking at and
asking for stock compensation for
companies this was a godsend as we
discussed it's way easier for companies
to pay stock compensation than pay cash
compensation this is the main reason
that compensation at Big tech companies
is so high unless you're at an entry
level 50 or more of the compensation is
stock the best part for companies was
that they didn't even have to convince
employees to take stock compensation
employees were literally asking for it
and with that the last Domino had fallen
none of this is to say that companies
want to lose money but they are more
tolerant of losses than ever before and
as long as there's more growth to
achieve companies are willing to stay at
break-even operations indefinitely a
great example of this is Salesforce
every single year their revenue has gone
up but their net income has virtually
nothing in comparison to their revenue a
similar story can be seen with Shopify
and Amazon and Uber and Airbnb and
Zillow and basically every modern tech
company that you can think of as long as
the company is growing neither the
employees or the founders nor the
shareholders care about profit for all
three of these groups having the company
make no money is counterintuitively the
most lucrative option as no money is
being siphoned by taxes and everything
can be reinvested into further growth
now we should also mention that many of
these companies are starting to realize
that there's no such thing as infinite
growth but that's a whole other story if
you're in a company would you go after
profit or growth comment that down below
also drop a like if you would like to
see more videos about tech companies and
their inner workings and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community together ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions are
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
foreign